we're not talking about the extreme most
paralyzing regions of despair where
external medical help is vital
our target is rather the times when we
feel as indicated by Thoreau's phrase
mired in needs of quiet desperation a
large gray hinterland in which beneath
an outward surface of endurance we feel
exhausted close to tears
beyond the sympathetic understanding of
others easily irritated and daunted by
the simplest tasks they will probably
have been certain triggers for our
melancholy an intimate rejection a
humiliation around work the growing
realization that the ambitious plans of
earlier years have come to very little
unfortunately sadness feels very taboo
societies tend slyly to insist on
cheerfulness we end up not only
struggling but humiliated that we're in
such difficulties yet in truth there is
nothing more natural or routine than
grief we have so much to film a roasts
about simply by virtue of being alive we
will inevitably so often feel badly
misunderstood unfairly criticized
overlooked and rejected will be struck
by our own stupidity and appalled by our
inner ugliness and cowardice we will
make some shockingly poor decisions we
will let others down and we will witness
those we love suffer and die before
ourselves having to give up the keys to
life the reasons for feeling low and
demoralized touch more or less everyone
it is the universality the normality of
suffering that makes the sight of small
happy children so poignant we know as
they cannot yet how much they're going
to suffer
we don't know the precise details but we
know that in some way or another a
distinctive range of Horrors will in
time befall them every day almost
without noticing it we have to fight off
a range of incoming
powerful reasons not to despair we rely
on an internal engine a muscle of hope
to pump out consoling flames then one
day the task seems too much the muscle
can't take it anymore at such times we
need to keep a few ideas in mind for a
start that sorrow is not an individual
failing it is a basic reality for our
entire species we are so extremely
sensitive such fragile constructions
constantly exposed to danger for the
most part blind hopeful without regard
to reality and with unquenchable needs
for love and sympathy our tribulations
are a symptom of being human never just
a curse attached to our sliver of
existence others who might seem
successful buoyant and composed will
travel at moments they shield us from to
the very same places of despair we have
been exiled to we live so close to
ourselves we know so much about our own
private failings we miss that our flaws
are in fact general present even in the
outwardly Placid the beautiful the rich
and the people next door if only we
could see into their minds we would feel
so much less alone we are it's true
sometimes hard to be around we're easy
to caricature as grumpy in a pain but in
truth was sad rather than mean anxious
rather than bad it's hard to make on
despair sound Charlie to present
ourselves in the way that would win us
the compassion we so require yet were
being harder on ourselves than we would
be on a friend we should at the least a
quarter selves the same degree of
forgiveness
we wouldn't hesitate to direct to an
acquaintance in the end however tempting
it is we can't just abandon our lives
there are too many people who rely on us
even if their presence doesn't feel real
right
now above all we don't know the future
it's the other side of our dependence on
chance
things can get slightly better for
reasons it's hard to foresee justice
pleasures fade and can seem meaningless
in retrospect so pains at least
sometimes can pass or soften things we
thought we'd never be able to get over
gradually become available to get just
on mental posture we stoop to
accommodate a new
being miserable does not exclude us from
the human community it's a sure sign
that we are very normal and that life is
progressing in its own dark way more or
less exactly to plan
you